if your game lacks bytes come and play
around at this course near Brisbane but
be on your guard at the 14th tee because
this is probably the world's only
shark-infested golf course in the lake
in the middle of the course live half a
dozen man-eating bull sharks during
heavy floods they were washed onto the
course from a nearby river when the
water receded the Sharks was stranded
of course flooded the Logan River so it
flooded at the time now the general
manager of car Brook Golf Club gets some
interesting reactions from visiting
players you can't believe how close you
are that's probably the biggest thing I
mean you're only if he's six feet away
you know I said I just sort of normally
they just step back and they they say
something I won't repeat but tell ya
they're just amazed the sharks are
thriving in the wells stocked lake even
breeding a couple a close to ten foot
long they're sometimes given the old
treat one even had a nibble at our
camera what's he like working on a
shark-infested golf course so right now
you're too close
and so yeah nothing this close obviously
there is Ella
in the past local kids used to jump in
the lake here to collect lost golf balls
for a bit of extra pocket money funnily
enough no amount of money or get them to
go in the lake today Australia's most
famous golfer Greg Norman was nicknamed
the shark but what des members think of
their version first time I ever saw him
with some men were feeding and he came
up and it was just like jaws coming that
play out of the water
girls were yeah three hey this is joke
and I was just about to hit my ball I
wasn't impressed do you get a bit scared
when you play it's really exciting when
we see it water hazards are tricky for
any golfer but this must be the ultimate
the sharks are quite a draw there's even
a shark Lake challenge an increasingly
popular tournament players love getting
their teeth into Jonathan Samuels Sky
News Brisbane